manchmal gerade fragen wer von ihnen
schon mal auf diesem youtube kanal war
okay also fast alle wenn sie darauf
schon gewesen waren oder kürzlich
gewesen waren
sollte ihn dieses neue video hier wie
schreibe und format ihre ich
philosophische hausarbeiten hier nicht
entgangen sein
gehen sie mal drauf ich klicke mal kurz
drauf und dann
samsung genommen
formatiert
[Musik]
für uns
china
können sie
die
si
[Musik]
so als so fällt dazu nur ich will das
jetzt gar nicht weiter ausbreiten ich
will ihnen nur sagen gehen sie drauf
schauen sie sich an falls sie es noch
nicht wissen
ich mache noch eine weitere themen
sendung die ausschließlich dem thema und
dem problem des plagiats gewidmet sein
wird auch ein spannendes thema muss man
auch mal video dazu machen ok in der
nächsten sitzung sowie kann ich jetzt
schon sagen werde ich auch noch mal ein
paar mögliche themen für hausarbeiten
ihnen vorstellen dass sie ein bisschen
mal seine orientierung bekommen wir sind
jetzt sehr weit gediehen
wir haben meines wissens noch mit also
diese recht diese sitzung nicht
eingerechnet noch drei sitzungen bis zum
semesterende wenn mich wenn ich recht
gezählt haben
daher können wir noch einiges machen
immanuel kant wollen wir auf jeden fall
machen und vielleicht am ende noch einen
höheren position vielleicht schopenhauer
oder seite betrifft finde ich viel
spannender als schopenhauer muss ich
selbst sagen aber wir schauen mal wie es
von der zeit her reicht ok dann gehen
wir mitten in die sache hinein diesen
herrn kennen sie wer ist das nochmal
immanuel kant wie aristoteles saison
lockt er ist es richtig das ist alles
total ist und ja natürlich
und er hat
ein versuch über den menschlichen
verstand geschrieben der 1690 erschien
und in diesem werk hat john lobb wie
auch andere denker des britischen
empirismus also es gibt die sie
vielleicht wissen drei große denker des
britischen imperiums als empirismus ist
die these als man von etwas empirismus
bedeutet das was meint diese
philosophische position des empirismus
das sollten vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz hier
und was ist die gasag die position des
imperiums dh das was bedeutet der
begriff oder das wort empirismus welches
andere wort steckt da drin wissen sie es
sie kennen das wort sicherlich also es
ist eigentlich da drinnen einfach mal
melden wer hatte sie dürfen einfach
hinein rufen ja ja
genau also es kommt von empirie
griechischen ursprungs und das ist die
wahrnehmung die erfahrung vielleicht
auch noch erfahrung das sind also
philosophen die die these vertreten dass
all das wenige was wir wissen oder
wissen können nur aus der erfahrung
entspringen kann also bezogen auf die
frage nach dem bisschen was können wir
wissen und dann sagen wenn wir wissen
wollen dann müssen wir auf die erfahrung
zurückgehen und die erfahrung war es
könnte jetzt die erfahrung zb sein was
ist sind die erfahrungen gehen sie zum
beispiel eine erfahrung durch die man
etwas wissen kann ja
haben wir spielten sich
genau das wäre so ein beispiel
das wäre jetzt ein beispiel einer
kausalen erfahrung die frage ist
natürlich die ob wir so was wie diese
notwendige verbindung von qualität von
ursache und wirkung ob er diese
notwendigkeit der kausalität ob wir die
überhaupt erfahren können
das ist ein großes problem bei an
weiteren englischen empirischen der
heißt britischen christen heißt david
hume ich komme gleich noch auf alle drei
zu sprechen
aber das wir so ein beispiel ich habe
etwas gesehen in der vergangenheit ich
habe es gesehen
immer wenn das der fall war dann war das
also zum beispiel sehen aber auch
natürlich riechen hören fühlen
diese ganzen szene die wir haben die
sind in dieser erfahrung vorhanden
und besonders wichtig ist natürlich der
sie sind das ist sondern wichtig aber
nicht nur und das nennen die das sind
alles sinnes daten oder auch perzeption
rezeption hat einfach nur aufgenommen
ist wahr genommen und die britischen
empires ist in die ich jetzt ihnen auch
noch mal hin schreibe also wir haben
jetzt schon einen den block wir sind sie
noch einen weiteren britischen imperiums
ich habe auch einen anderen schon
genannt gehabt kurz vorher vielleicht
lernen sich hatte den namen genannt
david hume genau das fehlt noch einer
ist nicht der ist nicht ganz so wichtig
gut herbst gibt es auch noch den maric
aber den thomas hobbes mache ich davor
dann haben wir nämlich gerade 4
jetzt haben wir noch den job dem
schreiben wörtlich aber man spricht die
bank
ich glaube so schreibt mir in berlin
spricht man aus das war ein ihre und das
war ein engländer
das war ein date jung kam aus schottland
ein schotte und der herbst ist glaube
ich als auch ein engländer glaube ich
das jedenfalls haben wir also alle
briten da wie vereint und das sind also
philosophen die sagen das was wir wissen
können muss zurück in auf unsere
erfahrung auf kombinationen von
verschiedenen sims daten der sitzung
also in diese ecke gehört und so heute
gar denker und jetzt gibt es natürlich
noch eine gegenposition zum empirismus
wissen sie wie man die gemeinhin nimmt
also dass nicht alles einfach so dagegen
gegen theorie die eben nicht sagt dass
das wissen primär aus der erfahrung
sturm
woher könnte denn das wissen sonst noch
stamm wenn es nicht aus der erfahrung
stammt ja
genau
wichtig das ist dann der nationalismus
als journalismus und hier ist es die
ratio alle die vernunft der verstand als
ratio heißt vernünftig am strand das
heißt das wissen muss zurück gehen auf
unser denken verstand vernunft und ja
was ist denn jetzt hier dann äquivalent
zum euro analog zum in paris muss dann
das objekt wurde der grund vielleicht
besser die quelle des wissens also nicht
sind es daten sind es wahrnehmung
sondern ja richtig also das hammer stoli
als erfahrung jetzt wäre die frage sei
was konkret na also analog zum begriff
der erfahrung des denkens und analog
jetzt zu fühlen hören riechen sehen wäre
es ja ich hab's nicht verstanden gut ja
ich glaube es geht in die richtige
richtung es geht also um begriffe
begriffe begriffe und ich sag mal noch
mal die logik logik oder logische
gesetze
da ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiger
vertreter den sie kennen können sie mir
einen ganz wichtigen vielleicht sowie
den wichtigsten oder nehmen sie mir doch
mal zwei wichtige vertreter des
rationalismus einem werden wir heute
noch behandeln die karts und ja der
kante ist ein spezialfall es er ist eher
ein rationalist aber wir werden heute
noch einen behandeln die sozialisten
leibnitz genau aber sie liegen mit kann
nicht ganz falsch aber kann ist noch
eine spezial sache auf dem kommen noch
zu sprechen
also wir haben hier den rené descartes
und dann noch den alten hits
gottfried wilhelm leibnitz ist glaube
ich leibnitz und die sagen also müssen
um zum wissen zu gelangen uns auf unsere
begriffe konzentrieren
manche sagen auch eingeborene ideen das
ist dann wie bei platons ein bisschen
platt und sagt dass auch ricard sagt wir
müssen auf unser ich reflektieren
unser selbstbewusstsein und jetzt haben
wir hier noch immer anerkannt und den
nennt man dann nicht mehr ein
rationalist ist wie nennt man den ich
greife jetzt mal ein bisschen vorweg ja
ja im grunde schon nur ist er kein
reiner ideal ist also georg wilhelm
friedrich hegel wäre einer dieser
idealisten und auch fred jung
auch im friedrich wilhelm joseph
schelling und johann gottlieb fichte
sind idealisten im rhein sinne wenn sie
jetzt davor den idealismus noch eine
ergänzung setzen dann haben sie es genau
ein transzendentaler ideal ist das ist
jetzt ein schwieriges wort
transzendentaler ideal ist das ist ganz
schwierig kurz gesagt was damit gemeint
es ist eigentlich folgendes kant bringt
diese beiden theorien hier
empirismus und rationalismus die bringt
der zusammen
man könnte sagen es eine art synthese
von empirismus und rassismus ganz
zentraler idealismus bedeutet was
bedeutet das idealismus bedeutet
natürlich dass der jeweilige gegenstand
des wissens nicht empirisch ist sondern
von unserer subjektivität abhängt von
unserer erkenntnis subjektivität kurz
gesagt trans zentrale idealismus meint
zum beispiel dass solche dinge sage
jetzt mal anführungsstrichen wie raum
und zeit
solche phänomene wie raum und zeit dass
die nicht unabhängig von unserer
erkennenden subjektivität existieren
sind das die ganz eng mit unserer
subjektivität zusammenhängen also raum
und zeit existieren nicht objektiv
unabhängig von uns erkennen den
subjekten und das meint eben dieser
idealismus transzendentale weint sagen
die rahmenbedingungen unserer erkenntnis
die bedingungen der möglichkeit und zur
erkenntnis die rahmenbedingungen
innerhalb deren erkenntnis watt
stattfinden kann
und das ist zum beispiel raum und zeit
und über diese sachen raum und zeit sagt
eben kann sie sind nicht objektiv
unabhängig von uns erkennen subjekten da
sondern wir als erkennt gewesen wir
bringen die irgendwie mit beschreibt es
immer so dass wir dann verschiedene
rahmungen vornehmen
das sind diese trans zentralen
bedingungen und in diesen rahmen gibt es
dann diese cinestar dieses
sinneswahrnehmung
also diese sie müssen sie so verstehen
diese aktien das sind solche perzeption
zum beispiel rot eindruck ein bestimmter
geruch ein bestimmtes zins eindruck dass
sind so eindrücke und die beschreibe ich
jetzt mal zwischen x10 und kann sagt ich
habe diese action auch noch das ist mein
tribut an den im tourismus aber ich habe
auch noch gewisse rahmenbedingungen
gewisse begriffe die diese x10 diese
sind es daten erst ordnen die überhaupt
ihn erst ihren platz zuweisen und
deswegen kann man sagen es kann nicht
nur reiner ettal ist wäre er ein reiner
idealist hätte er keine x10 hier drin
dann wird er nämlich sagen dieses daten
wie zum beispiel rot und blau oder ein
gewisser geruch die stammen alle nur aus
unserem zug aus unserer subjektivität
das erkannt nicht kann sagt gewisse
dinge müssen uns gegeben werden von
außen wie zum beispiel sinneseindrücke
blautöne die können wir nicht selbst
produzieren ich kann jetzt nicht sagen
ich möchte jetzt diesen stuhl hier in
wird sich in grünen sehen ich wünsche
mir jetzt diesen stunden grünen system
das geht nicht also ist hängt nicht von
unserer subjektivität das muss gegeben
sein und deswegen ist also ein trans
zentraler ideal ist also trans zentral
das sind dann diese diese rahmungen
bezüglich dieser rahmen ist er ein
idealist das heißt nicht dass die uns
jetzt will endlich zur verfügung stehen
raum und zeit und solche kategorien sind
dass die eben mit unserer subjektivität
zu tun haben und nicht von außen kommen
das ist in aller kürze diese dieser
fahrplan also wir haben jetzt drei
stationen
ich möchte ich aber auch gar nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen und jedenfalls
kant ist so eine art synthese von
empirismus und catalis muss und hier
könnte ich sagen denken begriffe sind
nur solche kästchen die ordnungs
kästchen und damit man diese beiden
sachen zusammen bringen hier
diese x10 diese kästchen dann bekommen
hier also kann es hat durchaus auch noch
eine empirische seite an sich weil er
sagt die sind es daten müssen uns
gegeben sein
die anschauungen das kann die müssen
meistens gegeben sein wir bringen die
begriffe mittel und dann kommt eben so
was dabei raus ja das ist jetzt mal nur
seine kurze generelle einordnung und
jetzt kommen wir auf diesen im ersten
block zu sprechen und wir haben uns ein
paar leitfragen überlegt nämlich
vertritt lockt eine theorie von
handlungs oder willensfreiheit ganz
spannende frage auf den ersten blick
verrate ich ihnen schon scheint es so
als ob er nur eine theorie der
handlungsfreiheit vertreten würde
wenn sie aber genauer hinschauen und da
möchte ich mal was drüber schreiben ist
nicht ganz ausgereift wenn sie genau
hinschauen werden sie sehen dass ich da
doch trotzdem ansätze von
willensfreiheit finden lassen also
solche grob klassifizierung sind auf den
ersten blick erstmal sehr hilfreich
genauso wie die klassifizierung von
empirismus und rationalismus aber wenn
sie genauer mal hinschauen werden sie
feststellen so empirisch tisch ist der
john lobb auch wieder nicht und so im
touristisch ist der david hume auch dann
nicht mehr
sie finden dabei diesen denken immer
auch momente der jeweils anderen
tradition
deswegen muss man solche groß
klassifizierung wie handlungsfreiheit
theoretiker willens theoretiker imperial
ist immer so ein bisschen mit vorsicht
genießen wie verhalten sich wiederum
verstand zueinander
wer oder was kann nach lockt eigentlich
frei genannt werden das ist vielleicht
das größte verdienst von john lobb dass
er hier so ein bisschen die rede von der
freiheit also von dem prädikat frei mal
ein bisschen problematisiert wir reden
immer so davon als sei der wille frei
und schon lockt wird sagen als wenn sich
etwas merken müssen dann das schon
nutzen hat lockt sagt der wille ist
nicht frei er kann gar nicht frei
genannt werden
das ist also ein begrifflicher
widerspruch sagen dass der wille frei
wäre
also das ist erst mal eine sehr contra
intuitive these von jean lacaba hat gute
argumente dafür könnten sie in ihre
hausarbeit man sich dieses thema
vorsetzen
warum ist nach john lobb der wille nicht
frei john lockes argumente gegen die
freiheit des willens
die könnten sie allemal entlang des
originaltextes mal auf liszt
rekonstruieren also sprechen eigenen
worten wiedergeben vielleicht auch ein
bisschen formalisieren und am ende dann
bewerten und schauen überzeugen mich
diese argumente die tochter bringt oder
kann ich nicht mit den rückgriff auf
einen anderen denker denn wir behandelt
haben zum beispiel mit kant oder mit
leibniz die these von john bock
kritisieren also so könnten sie dann an
eine hausarbeit herangehen
genau
genommen
die fragen sind
wichtig er kommt aber ausdrücklich
natürlich auf die frage zu sprechen ob
der wille frei ist
das werden wir heute lesen
eine falsche frage genau aber er bringt
argumente dafür bringt argumente
ja
diese form halte
und dann noch eine andere ware
wir müssen schauen ob er da noch diese
zwischen wollen und wille ein
unterschied macht jedenfalls hat er
verschiedene argumente die die these
einer wilden zweit bestreiten und diese
argumente wollen wir heute in der
heutigen sitzung gemeinsam
nachvollziehen
gehen wir mal hier einfach mal ein
bisschen nochmal durch wir gehen derzeit
ein bisschen schneller durch wir haben
in der letzten sitzung ja uns schon
ausführlicher mit ihm beschäftigt gehabt
wir wollen ja heute auch ein bisschen
auch die leibnitz zu sprechen kommen ich
lese deswegen einfach mal hier so ein
bisschen zügiger durch also überall da
wo das denken oder das vermögen der
weisung des denkens entsprechend zu
handeln oder nicht zu handeln völlig
fehlt tritt die notwendigkeit ein diese
heißt zwang wenn bei einem wesen das
eine willensäußerung fähig ist der
beginn oder die fortsetzung einer
handlung zudem im widerspruch steht was
der geist bevorzugt sie heißt hemmung
wenn die verbindung oder beendigung
einer handlung seiner willensäußerung
und widerspricht handelnde wesen die
überhaupt kein ding und keine willens
äußerungen haben sind in jedem fall
notwendig handelte dresen
bei diesen notwendig handelnden wesen
kann man nicht mehr belegt ist dass ein
warnton nachher in frankfurt nicht ganz
genau aber es geht so ein bisschen in
diese richtung
also wir haben eine willensäußerung oder
ein vermögen
dem denken der weisung des denkens
entsprechend zu handeln oder
nichthandeln und wenn das vermögen fehlt
wenn wir es nicht können dann nennen wir
das notwendigkeiten
also wir haben eine weisung des denkens
beweis und des denkens da müssen wir uns
mal genau überlegen was das ist also
unser ding und wir sind überzeugt davon
irgendetwas zu tun tun zu wollen
das ist die weisung unseres denkens oder
unsere unserer verstand sagt uns dass
das jetzt das beste für uns wäre diese
handlungen auszuführen
und wenn wir nach dieser weisung des
denkens nicht handeln können
bzw handeln wenn uns diese alternative
fehlt dann sind es ein bisschen die
frage nach dieser weisungen zu handeln
also ist die notwendigkeit jetzt darin
zu sehen dass wir nicht nach der weisung
des denkens handelns können oder ist die
notwendigkeit darin zu sehen dass wir
gar keine alternativen möglichkeiten
bezüglich der weisung des denkens haben
wir lesen sie das gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten
die lesen sind es entsprechend der
weisung des denkens zu handeln oder
nichts an
wir haben da eine weisung unseres
denkens unser verstand sagt uns dass wir
jetzt das beste diese situation und wann
trägt jetzt die notwendigkeit ein wenn
wir nicht danach handeln können oder
wenn wir gar nicht diese weisung des
denkens ihren alternativen alternativen
überhaupt willentlich erwägen können wie
würden sie sind spannende sache weil im
einen fall würde john lockt er als ein
handlungs theoretiker der freiheit
gelten im anderen ihr als ein
willensfreiheit theoretiker wie lesen
sie es
also ich habe auf den ersten blick habe
ich so gelesen als wäre schon lockt ein
handlungsfreiheit theoretiker also nicht
das tun können was man will aber wenn
ich genau nachdenken
dieses entsprechend zu handeln oder
nicht zu handeln könnte ich auch mir
vorstellen dass hier so eine art
willensfreiheit theorie implizit
zugrunde liegt nämlich sein eigenes
wollen noch mal hinterfragen können
müssen erst mal noch offen gelassen also
so eindeutig ist das nicht was jetzt
hier schon lockt sagt man jetzt kommt
die große these dass es am rand dieses
textes ist das immer so eine art
überschrift und da haben sie auch
gelesenen text die freiheit betrifft
nicht den willen und das ist jetzt die
hauptthese von schon lockt wenn dies
richtig ist und ich glaube dass dies der
fall es zugeben ich zu denken ob es
nicht dazu beitragen könnte eine lange
erörterte und meines erachtens wohl
vernünftige weil unverständliche frage
aus der welt schaffen diejenigen nämlich
ob der wille des menschen freizeit oder
nicht wenn ich mich nicht täusche folgt
aus meinen darlegung dass die frage als
solche vollkommen falsch gestellt ist
die frage ob der wille des menschen frei
ist ebenso sinnlos wie die ob sein
schlaf geschwind oder seine tugend
viereckig soll
denn die freiheit lässt sich ebenso
wenig auf den willen anwenden wie die
geschwindigkeit einer bewegung auf den
schlaf oder die figur eines 4x auf die
tugend über die absurdität von fragen
wie die beiden letzten würde jeder
lachen weil es klar zu tage liegt dass
die modifikationen der bewegung nichts
mit dem schlaf die figuren nichts mit
drogen zu tun haben ebenso deutlich wird
meiner meinung nach jeder die die sache
recht betrachtet einsehen dass die
freiheit die nur eine kraft ist
lediglich handelnden wiesen zukommt und
nicht ein attribut oder eine
modifikation des bildes sein kann
der gleichfalls nur
die kraft ist jetzt haben wir hier
mindestens zwei argumente diesem
textabschnitt den ich für den
zentralsten textabschnitt halte diese
ganzen berg die wir jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen hier gemeinsam analysieren
können was sind jetzt die argumente
versuchen sie die man noch mal so ein
bisschen den eigenen worten hier
wiederzugeben haben leider nur eine
tafel
lasst uns jetzt hier das argument
er sagt offensichtlich die frage ist der
wille freilich nicht sagte das ist
eigentlich eine würde man das heutzutage
nennen
oder man könnte mit wittgenstein sagen
es ist ein schein problem ja unsere
sprache verhext unseren verstand also
die weise wie wir über den willen reden
die ist einfach sprachlich schon falsch
es ist könnte man vielleicht sagen muss
man noch genau überlegen es ist
vielleicht nur eine eigentliche rede
oder eine metaphorische rede
sie werden feststellen wenn sie mal
genau ihren sprachgebrauch betrachten
dass sie sehr sehr häufig und zwar
unbewusst metaphorisch reden
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel es werden
sie auf anhieb gar nicht merken gegen
mit dem haus wenn die sagen das war
jetzt aber eine kurze zeit
das ist aber schnell gewesen oder das
war jetzt aber ganz schön lange zeit die
das gebraucht hat das ist doch
eigentlich total verständlich aber
eigentlich ist die rede falsch weil die
zeit kann ich langsam die zeit hat keine
räumliche ausdehnung zeit ist nichts was
räumlichen begriffen angemessen
beschrieben werden kann
wir reden als über die zeit so als ob
wir einen räumlichen gegenstand treten
würden und das führt uns in verschiedene
probleme dann wie freundlich in die zeit
obwohl das total selbstverständlich ist
hat die zeit lang die zeit ist kurz die
zeit verrinnt
da wird dann schon klar dass es eine
metapher ist die zeit ist nichts
flüssiges die zeit ist kein wasser er
will seine zeit verrinnt dann reden wir
über die zeit wie ein wasserlauf wurde
wie ein sanduhr wie ein sand eine sand
ansammlung die durch einen über durch
eine enge durch einen flaschenhals
tropft da fließen würden reden wir ohne
eigentlich wir reden über die zeit als
ob sie ein flüssiges medium werden
und ähnlich ist es auch hier mit dem
willen als es nach kategorien fehler
stichwort kategorien fehler also so wie
wenn wir fragen ob das wir sagen dass
die trugen vier eckig sein hier
da würden wir auch sofort sagen ja das
sagt ist doch unsinn so über die tugend
zu reden
dieser begriff das prädikat viereckig
passt gar nicht zum zu seinem objekt
oder zusagen subjekt genauer gesagt na
also subjekt prädikat objekt prädikat
das objekt ist tugend und das prädikat
ist eben vier eckig sein
er würde sagen das ist eine falsche zu
schreiben subjekt und prädikat passen
nicht zusammen
und so sagt er genauso ist es wie wenn
wir wenn wir von dem willen sagen er ist
frei also ich versuche dass man hier so
ein bisschen an der tafel nochmal
übersichtlicher darzustellen
[Applaus]
also wir können jetzt hier sagen
die kugel ist viereckig und wir können
sagen
der wille ist frei und das wären acht
schon lockt genau dasselbe
von der struktur wir haben hier das
subjekt prädikat und da die stehen
einfach in einem widerspruch wir können
dieses prädikat gar nicht dem subjekt zu
schreiben es passt nicht so wenn wir
sagen würden
dieser stuhl hier ist neidisch würden
wir sagen das ist eine poetische rede
da ist eine poetische an eigentliche
rede was passt einfach nicht
dieses prädikat kann gar nicht auf
dieses subjekt passen
all das ist ein argument bzw
erst mal ohne tees und jetzt muss man
mal zwei punkte anschauen und das ist
jetzt diese untersten drei zeilen hier
hier führte viertletzte ebenso deutlich
wird meiner meinung nach jeder der die
sache recht betrachtet einsehen dass die
freiheit die nur eine kraft ist
lediglich handelnden wesen zukommt und
nicht an attribut oder eine modifikation
des wesens sein kann des willens sein
kann der gleichfalls noch eine kraft
was jetzt jedes argument versuchen sie
es nochmal eigenen worten zu formulieren
schauen sie sich noch einmal den satz
hier an der wille ist frei
was hat jetzt zu diesen zwei
bestandteilen es sagt jetzt dann auf
mich er was sagt jetzt über die ebenen
beziehung von wille und freiheit
ja kein weg an den rebellen sondern
benutzt werden muss und im internet
es geht in die richtige richtung
er würde schon aber sagen glaube ich
dass freiheit einen modus ist oder eine
qualität ist oder eine kraft ist nur
würde er glaube ich sagen dass eben der
wille selbst auch eine kraft ist das
problem wäre dann das eine kraft die
kraft hätte
der wille ist eine kraft und die
freiheit ist auch eine kraft die sind
praktisch auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt und attribute oder prädikate
können sie nicht aufeinander beziehen
wir können nicht eine prädikat ein
prädikat zu sprechen
ja das ist glaube ich das problem also
dass die eigentlich auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt sind und er will sich nicht
eignet als ein subjekt sondern will
müsste auch so eine art prädikat sein
oder modus also motti können sie nicht
aufeinander beziehen die schönheit kann
nicht gelb sein müssen wir reden jetzt
allerdings so und das ist das problem
das wir reden jetzt von solchen modell
wurde von solchen kräften oder von
attributen so als ob sie substanzen
seien als ob sie mögliche träger von
attributen zeit also wir neigen dazu
bestimmte freie modi unseres vollzugs
oder bestimmte qualitäten unseres
handelns die nach aigen mir mit händen
dazu diese qualitäten unseres handelns
zu vergeben ständig als die qualitäten
zu subjekten oder substanzen zu machen
und denen dann wieder eigenschaften
zuzusprechen
und das geht also nach schon lockt nicht
die sind als auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt und nicht so dass eben einem
subjekt was sie immer ob übergeordnet
ist ja dass dem subjekt das prädikat
zugestimmt werden kann dann ist auch das
eben ebene angesiedelt und das ist wohl
eines dieser probleme
sehen sie es anders haben sie noch
andere ergänzungen beobachtungen dazu
als er sagt es ist ein kategorien fehler
es geht nicht aus verschiedenen gründen
geht es nicht er bringt aber noch
weitere argumente und die müssen wir uns
jetzt mal gemeinsam noch anschauen sagt
die schwierigkeit durch den wortlaut
innere vorgänge zu erläutern
diese innere vorgänge ist eben gerade
die bildung unseres willens klare
begriffen von ihnen zu geben ist so groß
dass ich meinen leser hier darauf
hinweisen muss dass die von mir
gebrauchten wendungen vorschreiben
bestimmen wählen vorziehen usw
die willensäußerung nicht deutlich genug
bezeichnen können solange man nicht sein
eigenes verhalten bleiben wollen
beobachtet beispielsweise ist vorziehen
das den akt der willens äußeren am
besten auszudrücken scheint doch keine
ganz genaue bezeichnung denn mancher
würde wohl das fliegen im gehen
vorziehen und doch wer kann jemals sagen
dass er fliegen wollte
die heutige schon brauchen uns nur so
ein jetpack darum zu schnallen und schon
geht's los
die willensäußerung ist offenbar ein akt
des geistes hier die herrschaft die er
sich selbst oder über irgendeinen teil
des menschen so schreibt wissentlich
ausübt indem er diesen teil mit einer
bestimmten handlung beschäftigt oder
england dieser handlung hindern
was aber ist der willen anderes als die
fähigkeit dies zu tun ist diese
fähigkeit im grunde wirklich mehr als
eine kraft nehme ich die kraft des
geistes sein denken zur hervorrufen
fortführung oder unterbrechung
irgendeiner handlung zu bestimmen soweit
das von uns abhängt den lässt sich
leugnen dass jedes wirkende wesen dass
dies kraft hat über seine eigenen
handlung nachts decken und einzuarbeiten
ihre ausführung oder ihre unterlassung
fortsetzen
die fähigkeit besitzt die wir würden
nennen der wille ist demnach nichts
anders an als eine solche kraft freiheit
dagegen ist die macht der mensch hat
eine bestimmte handlung zu tun oder zu
unterlassen
je nachdem
das eine oder andere in seinem geist
tatsächlich den vorzug genießt das heißt
mit anderen worten ausgedrückt je
nachdem wie er es selbst will man jetzt
frage ich sie noch mal in diesem letzten
zeilen hier vertritt jetzt hier schon
lockt eine tätige handlungsfreiheit oder
der wille zu weit was würden sie sagen
geht es hier um die bestimmung unseres
willens wollen können was man will
oder tun können was man will
als alba nummer hier freiheit dagegen
ist die macht der mensch hat eine
bestimmte handlung 200 zu erlassen je
nachdem das einen anderen geist
tatsächlich den vorzug genießt
er würde sagen es handlungsfreiheit
einfach mal melden wer sagt dass
handlungsfreiheit
wer sagt dass willen 2 okay die
handlungsfreiheit theoretiker war warum
sagen sie handlungsfreiheit gebe es
immer argumente
ja
die kraft des willens ungehindert
ja tun können was man will
gibt es andere thesen auch die ihren
willen zweier theorie sprechen
haben sie noch andere argumente
warum haben sich einige von ihnen noch
gemeldet zum thema willensfreiheit noch
andere argumente
die frage ist immer die und das hatte
mich auch ganz am anfang so ein bisschen
irritiert bei dem ersten zitat müssen
wir unser eigentliches die weisung des
denkens müssen die um frei zu sein diese
war diese weisung des denkens oder unser
wollen noch mal selbst zum gegenstand
machen können wesentlich als davon frei
sein
oder müssen wir nur das was unsere
weisung des denkens vorgibt tun können
und da ist eine gewisse ambivalenz
bahnlog gegeben glaube ich aus dieser
passage würde ich jetzt auch ernst
nehmen dass es nur in anführungsstrichen
handlungsfreiheit ist haben wir wie
schon gesagt wurde eine bestimmte
handlung zu tun oder zu unterlassen je
nachdem das ein oder andere begeisterte
ihn vor so genießt wenn der geist eben
das eine vorzieht und ich das dann auch
tun kann dann bin ich frei
handlungsräume die frage ist ob wir auch
noch über die vorzüge des vorziehen des
geistes die präferenzen des geistes ob
wir über die auch noch mal selbst
reflektieren können müssen frei zu sein
es gibt eine passage wo schon lockt es
nahe liegt dann wäre das eine theorie
der willensfreiheit implizit auch wenn
er die ja eigentlich begrifflich jetzt
schon ausgeschlossen hat aber ich glaube
das ist eben so einfach nicht ist nicht
nur so ein typischer vertreter der
handlungsfreiheit ist glaube ich hat
aber das scheint mir auch erst mal nur
in richtung handlungsweise kinder sie am
ende sagten ja
[Musik]
ja gute punkt hatte der der wille ist
nichts anderes als
eine fähigkeit genau als eine kraft des
geistes
hallo hier noch einmal der wille ist
nichts anderes als eine solche kraft des
vorziehen
eine kraft und frei ist die macht
ganz ähnlich ja gute frage aber was
jetzt müsse man sich fragen was ist der
unterschied zwischen willen und freiheit
weil er sagt ja hier freiheit dagegen
als scheint eben nicht genau dasselbe zu
sein so unterschiedlich
ja ich glaube es geht in die richtige
richtung also wir haben jetzt hier den
unterschied zwischen kraft und macht
kraft bezeichnet den willen und macht
die freiheit
als ich denke freiheit ist noch ein
bisschen mit mir darüber diskutieren
freiheit ist noch ein bisschen mehr als
nur kraft bei kraft wären nur das
vermögen also die möglichkeit und eine
kraft muss ja auch noch verwirklicht
werden ich glaube dass sich wille und
freiheit gegenüberstehen wie möglichkeit
und wirklichkeit also der wille ist an
eine potenz eine kraft eine fähigkeit
ein vermögen
da haben wir aber dann schon drin das
vermögen ist doch auch die macht
ich habe die macht habe ich glaube der
punkt ist dass wir müssen natürlich
jetzt englische noch mal gehen
also ich glaube power ist dann power ist
dann die macht bzw
zuschauen ist power die kraft oder die
macht müssen wir jetzt nachschauen unter
punkt des liefer jedoch nach aber es ist
glaube ich so dass wirklich will ihr das
vermögen ist eine kraft und freiheit ist
dann der vollzug und die verwirklichung
dieser markt zb könnte ich den willen
haben etwas zu tun und auch das vermögen
haben es zu tun und es dennoch nicht
machen
normalerweise würde schon sagen wenn ich
den willen habe und das vermögen habe
etwas zu tun
dann tu ich es auch am ende also ich
glaube dass der unterschied der ist das
bei der freiheit noch die handlung dazu
gedacht wird an die freiheit schließt
immer die verwirklichung des willens in
einer hand und bein nach schon lockt und
der wille noch nicht will ist das was
vor der hand liegt wäre zwar meine
thesen aber da ist noch eine meldung
der wille der auszugsweise mögen uns
noch mal nachschauen
artikel
im verständnis der eine permanente
morgen etwas sein was jeweils in einem
nicht immer
alles wäre jetzt eine gegenthese dazu
jedenfalls die dynamische dynamisch ist
ja die dass oder dann die potenz ja
solche sachen es ist nur potenziell es
ist der der macht und die energie jana
das also am werk es seien also wo dann
eben das ganze schon wirklich
verwirklicht wird dann wäre dann
vielleicht ihr die freiheit
also das wäre die möglichkeit aber ich
gebe ihnen zu das ist nicht klar
und ich werde eben bei der
zusammenfassung der heutige sitzung noch
dann die englischen original begriffe
nach erreichen die eben einmal also es
geht hier letztlich um kraft es geht
hier um die kraft und es geht hier um
die macht darüber müssen wir dann müssen
wir drastische länge schon ist ich
liefere ihnen ist auf jeden fall nach
also meine jetzige these wäre wille ist
nur die potenz also das vermögen und die
freiheit schließt immer die
verwirklichung des vermögens mit ein
aber müssen wir noch mal schauen wie es
im englischen text heißt
b
ja
[Musik]
die bedenken der bewegung
wir gehen jetzt noch mal zurück sie
haben schon recht hier in dem zitat
obwohl sagte dass die freiheit nur eine
kraft ist der wille ist gleichfalls noch
eine kraft das ist richtig das ist
richtig aber ich glaube ja also ich
glaube aber das ist also dass die kräfte
nicht auf der aus derselben perspektive
betrachtet werden ich glaube freiheit
ist die kraft unter dem gesichtspunkt
der verwirklichung
glauben sie nicht ja gut
gute frage ja kann man darüber
diskutieren wie sehen es die anderen sie
haben völlig zu recht darauf hingewiesen
also in dem zitat danach spricht er
jetzt hier von dagegen
also das ist dieses dagegen deutet für
mich darauf hin dass es eben doch eine
stärke unterscheidung gibt zwischen
wille und freiheit weil sich das dagegen
macht das ist wahrscheinlich however
oder so müsse man noch mal genau den
text schon habe sie weisen darauf hin
dass im vorherigen zitat hier
gleichfalls eine kraft ist sind jetzt
also kurz auf die frage sind sie jetzt
zwei verschiedene kräfte dafür würden
sie argumentieren wenn ich sie recht
verstanden habe sind
[Musik]
dieser text legt dies zumindest nahe
dass es nur eine kraft ist als sind es
dann zwei verschiedene kräfte oder und
das wird meine these ist es dieselbe
kraft nur einer verschiedene aspekt
betrachtet einmal die kraft im modus der
potenz einmal die kraft modus der
energija der der aktualität der
verwirklichung gedacht dieselbe kraft
auch mit auch nicht bei diskutieren
dessen jetzt erstmal zwei hermeneutische
ex ethischen probleme
[Musik]
wirklich
wieder unternehmensäußerungen
gut also das ist auf jeden fall ein
erneutes problem was wir haben
das müssen wir auf jeden fall erstmal
erst mal festhalten
und jetzt hier haben sie wieder dann
recht jetzt kommt das nächste zeit und
das liegt ihre lesart macht die wieder
ein bisschen stärke er sagt nämlich ist
es somit klar dass der wille
nichts ist als eine kraft oder fähigkeit
und jetzt kommt die freiheit eine andere
kraft oder fähigkeit das würde jetzt
wieder so ein bisschen ihre lesart
unterstützen ist ein anderes zwei
verschiedene typen oder arten von kraft
fragen ob die willensfreiheit so komme
heißt also wissen zu wollen
eine kraft eine andere kraft eine
fähigkeit eine andere fähigkeit besitze
was schon auf den ersten blick absurd
ist als dass man darüber streiten könnte
oder eine antwort darauf zu geben
braucht denn wir sehen nicht dass kräfte
nur handelnden wesen zu kommen und
ausschließlich angebote von substanzen
nicht aber von craft sind das war dieses
dieser punkt den wir hier hatten
wir dürfen den willen nicht so gebraucht
nicht so sehen als ob er eine substanz
wird oder im satz die stelle eines
subjekts so taktisch als als satz glied
ebenfalls glied dürfen eben nicht sind
taktisch die funktion eines subjekts zu
sprechen sondern es ist eigentlich immer
nur eine modifikation eigentlich ein
prädikat qualität also keine substanz
wir dürfen ihn nicht vergeben
stündlichen das ist eigentlich ziemlich
clever wir neigen dazu freiheit immer
vergeben stündlich und zu betrachten und
das macht eigentlich die freiheit gerade
kaputt weil kurz gesagt freiheit immer
etwas ist was ich im vollzug ergibt frei
ist nicht ein blog hier ein ding das ist
die freiheit unsere sprache liegt
natürlich nahe ist so über freiheit zu
reden das sagen die freiheit der wille
da reden wir dann so über den willen auf
derselben ebene wie wenn wir sagen der
stuhl die freiheit der wille ist frei
genau dieselbe weise wie der stuhl ist
rot also unsere syntaktische strukturen
lebten nahe also eine analogie aber dort
verführt uns unsere sprache wie ebit
gestellt sagen würde da unterliegen wir
der verhetzung und was verstand es durch
die sprache würde jetzt lockt sagen mit
wittgenstein wir dürfen so eigentlich
gar nicht über die freiheit reden wie
wir über einen tisch oder ein stuhl oder
sonst eine substanz
wäre und er ist auch kein handelndes
wesen als er ist kein akteur der wille
ist auch kein handels wesen
da die freiheit genau genommen nichts
anderem zugeschrieben werden kann wenn
man die freiheit in korrekter redeweise
überhaupt auf eine kraft anwenden kann
so lässt sich diejenige lässt sie sich
derjenige kraft zu schreiben die ein
mensch in sich hat um durchwahl oder
bevorzugen eine bewegung in einzelnen
teilen seines körpers zu erzeugen oder
die erzeugung zu unterlassen
das aber ist es gerade das hat man den
menschen freiheit
es ist die freiheit selbst sollte aber
jemand fragen ob die freiheit frei sei
so würde man von ihm annehmen dass er
seine harten worte nicht verstehen
denjenigen würde man die ohren des
mieters für würdig ansehen der wüste das
reich die bezeichnung von besitz von
reichtum sei und dennoch fragen würde ob
der reichtum selbst reich sein
ich lese die passage so dass er sich
hier ausdrücklich gegen eine konzeption
von willensfreiheit ausspricht als er
würde offensichtlich sagen dass die
frage ob wir frei sind wenn wir einen
bestimmten willen haben unsinnig ist als
wenn wir einen bestimmten bilden haben
etwas bevorzugen durchwahl oder
bevorzugung die kraft etwas zu
bevorzugen das sind wir diese kraft in
uns haben oder verspüren dass wir dann
nicht mehr fragen sind voll fragen
können ob wir das nochmal ob wir darin
frei sein können
sobald wir eine kraft in uns verspüren
etwas zu bevorzugen
nach unserem denken wünschen sind wir
frei das steht für ihn außer frage ob
die bevorzugung frei ist wird es sagen
ist sinnlos jetzt kann man aber kritisch
an
zum blog zurück fragen wie könnte man
jetzt zum beispiel zurückfragen
wir könnten denken sie mal noch mal
unsere vorhergehenden denker denken sie
zum beispiel an harry frankfurt oder
andere was könnte man jetzt hier den
einwänden gegen diese auffassung von
freiheit
man könnte zb fragen ja aber stammt denn
der wille selbst von dir oder bist du
nur in deinem wollen manipuliert durch
einen verrückten professor und eine
verrückte professor inge ja also man
müsste doch einiger fragen können muss
man nicht noch mal unser wollen selbst
hinterfragen als wir wollen können was
man will schon blog scheint es nicht für
nötig zu machen das sagt wenn wir in uns
den willen finden und eben die kraft
haben etwas zu tun was bevorzugt wird
dann ist das völlig hinreichend für
freiheit und willensfreiheit theoretiker
würden sagen leiden wir müssen
sicherstellen dass wir auch der der
autor unseres wollens unseres willens
sind als wir müssen nochmal auf unseren
willen reflektieren können dass dann
diese second order prinzip haben zu
lesen ich jetzt den passagen oder lesen
sie es ein bisschen anders
also das scheint mir so blogs argument
auch noch ein weiteres argument es sei
gegen die willensfreiheit und hier gibt
es durchaus kritikpunkte die man hier
jetzt anbringen kann
versucht es irgendwo im system von
freund verbrannt
die zweite kategorie
dieses 2
es wurde tatsächlich ich möchte dass ich
diesen unternehmen durch sehr gute frage
und ich glaube eben dass es sich nicht
lässt aber dass die frage sehr
berechtigt ist ich glaube das lockt hier
gegen dieses modell dieser zwei stufen
argumentiert
weil wenn er nämlich das zulassen würde
diese zwei stufen des wollens dann wäre
er ein willensfreiheit theoretiker dass
er aber nicht ist und wenn er eben nicht
diese nochmalige reflexion erforderlich
macht frei sein seinen willen zu wollen
das hält er für überflüssig wenn sie
etwas wollen dann wollen wir uns wir
müssen dieses wollen nicht noch mal
wollen können etwas zu wollen ist völlig
hinreichend wir kommen sonst in so ein
regress das ist das problem weiß auch
bei harry frankfurt immer höhere stufe
würde sagen auf einer ebene erreicht das
wir brauchen nicht noch eine zweite
ebene wenn wir etwas wollen dann wollen
wir es ist total okay
das heißt er braucht nicht diese zwei
stufen und deswegen ist ein
handlungsfreiheit theoretiker aber man
kann natürlich zurück fragen woher kommt
denn das wollen in uns es könnte doch
von außen induzierte wir werden geduld
ein verrückter professor eine verrückte
professoren manipuliert unser wollen
sodass wir glauben dass käme von uns
selbst dann würde schon lockt sagen ja
wenn wir das vor als empfinden und das
ungewollt ist okay natürlich könnte man
jetzt hier wiederum ansätzen sagen dass
wirklich unser will es sein muss spricht
da hiervon positiv pronomen schauen sie
mal rein spricht hier von unser unser
unser wille sein wille ihr bilden
ich sehe jetzt sie kein positiv pronomen
sagt ihr nicht unser wille oder
durch wahl oder benutzung er spricht ja
nicht von positiven sinne
nun scheint es einfach nur notwendigen
zu sein das wird den willen haben das
können wir nicht weiter fragen der wille
muss da von uns kommen wir müssen den
willen weiter hinterfragen und das macht
jetzt lockt hier nicht mehr
auch dann nicht aber war eine sehr
berechtigte frage ich glaube hier an
zieht man das eher tendenziell eher ein
theoretiker der handlungsfreiheit ist
nicht das edwin frey dessen kann die
bezeichnung fähigkeit vielleicht auch
pässe die die menschen die kraft die man
wählen end gegeben haben und die sie
dazu verleitet hat von gehen als von
einem handelnden wesen zu reden
durch eine den wahren sinn verhüllende
auslegung des wortes dazu dienen den
widersinn ein wenig zu momente
gleichwohl habe bezeichnet will in
wahrheit nichts anders als die kraft
oder fähigkeit vorzuziehen oder zu
wählen
sobald man den willen unter dem namen
fähigkeit als das ansieht was er
wirklich ist im lediglich an mit als die
kraft etwas zu tun
vertritt ohne weiteres zu tage wie
unsinnig es ist zu sagen soll frei oder
seien frei denn windows sinnvoll wäre
fähigkeiten als besondere wesen
anzunehmen
die handeln können und in diesem sinne
von ihnen zu sprechen was zum beispiel
geschieht wenn wir sagen der will viel
oder wille ist frei dann müssten wir
auch besondere fähigkeiten zum reden zum
gehen und zum tanzen annehmen
durch die die betreffenden federer
tätigkeiten erzeugt würden dabei sind
diese doch nur verschiedene modi der
bewegung ebenso betrachten wir wille und
verstand als fähigkeiten weil hier die
tätigkeiten des wählens und wahrnehmens
erzeugen während letztere doch lediglich
verschiedene modi zu wählen und
wahrnehmen um modi des dinkels man könne
dann ebenso gut sagen die fähigkeit des
singens singe und die fähigkeit des
tanzens tanze widerwille wehle und der
verstand begreife oder wie man sich oft
auszudrücken pflegt
der willen linke den verstand unter
verstand gehorche oder gehorche den
willen nicht denn ebenso passen und
verständlich wäre es zu sagen die kraft
zu reden lenke die kraft zu sehen oder
die kraft zu sehen gehorche oder
gehorchen nicht die kraft zu reden
das haben wir noch ein weiteres argument
was wieder in diese richtung geht dass
wir dazu neigen vermögen kapazität zu
substantially sieren das substantiv
ihren zu essentially sieren zur post
passieren
also was sagte jetzt was sind jetzt
wille und verstand wille und verstand
hier will und verstand die verhalten
sich zueinander was sind wir
einverstanden sind keine substanzen
keine entitäten sondern und theologisch
ausgedrückt er sagt es hier was sind sie
sie sagen
wir sagten die auftreten wenn etwas zu
finden
wir haben jetzt schon
oder oder subjekt nach dahinterstehen
würde genau ich glaube es sind also
vollzugs weisen oder betätigung weisen
unseres geistes oder unserer pension
wir können eben wollen wir können denken
wir können das machen aber der wille und
das denken sind nicht zwei instanzen in
uns sondern wir als person und als
mensch wir denken unser geist denkt
unser geist will und das ist ein
riesenproblem wie man davon reden soll
und das hat auch schon augustinus wie
früher behandelt
und er spricht davon dass alles reflexiv
ist also das alles aufeinander bezogen
ist
augustiner spricht er von der geist ist
in sich sehr reflexiv gestaltet es geht
bei dem geist auch um das wollen als der
geist will der geist erinnert sich der
geist denkt und diese ganzen motive
beziehen sich auf einander und in dem er
so eine reflexive modell des geist
entwickelt kann er gerade diese tendenz
der verdinglichung der substanz wie rung
substantially sierung diese akte
verhindern sagt alles eng mit anderen
zusammen das kann gar nicht getrennt wie
substanzen gedacht werden das hat also
einiges augustinus gelöst dieses problem
also wir dürfen jetzt nicht verschiedene
akte verschiedene akte so verstehen dass
dahinter jeweils eine substanz und
stände die das zu verantworten hatte es
sind letztendlich aus form vollzüge und
unseres geistes oder unserer person
gleichwohl ist diese art der
ausdrucksweise vorherrschen geworden hat
meiner ansicht nach große verwirrung
gestiftet
denn es handelt sich in den genannten
fällen durch weg um verschiedene dem
geiste eigene oder im menschen liegen
die kräfte zur verrichtung bestimmte
tätigkeiten dann faltet sie nach
belieben nicht aber wirkt die kraft eine
tätigkeit zu verbringen auf die kraft
eine andere tätigkeit zu verbringen ein
denn die kraft zu denken wird nicht auf
die kraft zu wählen
die kraft zu wählen nicht auf die kraft
zu denken ebenso wenig wie die kraft zu
tanzen auf die kraft zu singen ohne die
kraft zu singen auf die kraft zu tanzen
ein wirklich jeder bei einigen
nachdenken ohne weiteres einsehen wird
gerade das behaupten wir aber und wir
sagen dass der wille auf den verstand
und der verstand auf den weg als es sind
nicht unabhängige
entitäten sondern es sind die
unseres verhaltens
m
so
der 1
[Musik]
richtig das ist richtig aber eben nicht
so als ob es verschiedene dinge wären
die etwas wollte es sind eher äußerungen
aber ich glaube dass das mir diese so
vorstellen muss was er möchte ist er
möchte nicht er möchte nicht dass so
denken als ob hier als ob es hier
mobile verstand und meinetwegen noch die
freiheit gibt also als 3 und wii
entitäten sind was er möchte ist glaube
ich möchte zeigen dass es einfach
ausformungen des geistes sind oder des
menschen sind oder würden sie nicht so
auf der ich nur um zu behaupten dass die
inzwischen lässt sich nicht ableiten
an dicht
verschiedene sind das ist richtig aber
ich glaube dass man das so lösen kann
den man eben sagt ihr grund die wurzel
der einheits punkt ist eben der mensch
und wenn wir das so sehen dann können
wir eben sagen dann existieren sie nicht
mehr für sich getrennt sondern sie
existieren nur ins ob man sie auf den
menschen als vermögen kräfte des
menschen gesehen werden
da haben sie die einheit in der vielheit
aber ist noch nicht ganz müssen wir noch
weiter diskutieren wir kommen nämlich
jetzt noch gleich darauf zu sprechen und
dass jetzt der punkt kräfte sind
relationen nicht handeln gewesen
das ist jetzt der punkt ich gebe zu
dieser oder jener wirklich gehegte
gedanke kannte anlass zu einer
willensäußerung oder zur betätigung der
im menschen liegenden kraft zu wählen
sein oder ein wirklich erfolgtes willen
des geistes kann die ursache dafür
werden dass man tatsächlich an diesen
oder jenen gegenstand denkt so kann etwa
der wirkliche tönende gesang eine
bestimmte melodie die ursache für das
tanzen eines bestimmten tanzes und das
tanzen eines solchen tanz ist anders
wird das sehen
eine solche melodie seien aber mit all
diesen fällen wirken nicht eine kraft
auf eine anpassung der geist wirkt und
entfaltet diese kräfte der mensch
verrichtet die tätigkeit das tätig
gewesen hat die kraft oder ist fähig zu
handeln denn kräfte sind relationen
nicht handeln gewesen wo das was die
kraft zu wirken besitzt oder nicht
besetzt ist frei oder nicht frei die
kraft selbst ist es nicht in freier oder
unfreiheit kann nur dem zu kommen was
die kraft zu handeln besitzt oder nicht
nicht besitzt also würde ich das
vorschlagen hier
der geist der mensch hat kräfte mögen
und wenn er sie nicht hat dann ist er
eben nicht frei als es nicht so dass die
freiheit jetzt da ist also die freiheit
ist nur dann da wenn diese kraft da ist
bzw
die verwirklicht werden kann und wenn
sie und dass die verwirklichung dieser
kraft also vom effekt her betrachtet vom
vollzog er betrachtet das ist dann
freiheit also freiheit ist nur ein
vollzug des geistes er nimmt das eine
relation
ich weiß nicht ob relation besonders gut
ist wird sagen ein vollzug
oder vielleicht der effekt eines
vollzugs ich glaube dass eben jetzt die
frage ist hier wieder die wie verhalten
sich freiheit und wille sondern ich
glaube meine these aber sie haben gute
argumente dass es zwei verschiedene
kräfte sind ich würde ihr argumentieren
die freiheit ist der wille und einem
bestimmten aspekt nämlich unter dem
aspekt des volkes vollzogen science dass
in einer handlung umgesetzt
aber es gibt auch andere argumente wie
sie richtig sagen er sagt sind
verschieden ist alle anderen kraft wie
man das anders versteht anders im sinne
von zwei typen oder anders nur aus einer
anderen perspektive ich bin er soll
einer der sagt zwei aspekt theorie
[Musik]
ja ja ich denke eben das wilde und
freiheit doch noch enger zusammen hängen
aber wie gesagt es gibt jetzt hier die
zwei typen leser zu kann man das nennen
die zwei typen lesart oder die zwei
aspekte lesart das glas mir jetzt
einfach noch mal offen wir haben
argumente für beide ist können wir jetzt
hier vielleicht noch nicht mal genau
unterscheiden können sie dann sehr gerne
in einer hausarbeit zum beispiel machen
diese frage mag ein bisschen
ausführlicher nachgehen als wie es hier
jetzt waren
der nur sehr beschränkte zeit können
gestellt
ja
ja als sie haben zumindest nichts
miteinander zu tun
auf der app auf derselben ebene aber sie
haben was zu tun wenn man sie auf die
geister zieht nämlich der mensch kann
natürlich auch verstand und wille
gebrauchen und kann natürlich seinen
willen reflektieren
aber er macht es dann nicht so dass der
wille die freiheit oder der verstand den
willen reflektiert ich glaube das ist
der punkt als es nicht so dass jetzt
hier
das sagten sie auch dass der verstand
auch den willen gerichtet ist das ist
nicht der fall sondern es ist der geist
der hier die beiden in eine verbindung
bringt der also versteht eine akte
vollzieht so würde ich das sage also es
ist eben der einheits punkt des geistes
der seine verschiedenen vermögen
gebrauchen kann
aber es ist nicht so dass die vermögen
selbst akteure sind die sich aufeinander
beziehen sonst sie verziehen sich
vielleicht wenn sich aufeinander
beziehen nur vermögen des geistes diese
einheits ist haben sie haben meinen
lesern aber sie haben auch gute
argumente dafür dass sie eigentlich
strikt getrennt voneinander gedacht
werden müssten das müssen jetzt wieder
offen lassen jetzt sagt er hier noch
freiheit kommt nicht im bilde zu
haben wir schon gehabt genau das habe
ich schon gehört
ich gebe zu
ich glaube jetzt sagt ihr freiheit kommt
vielmehr dem handelnden wesen oder
menschen zu also frei kommt nicht den
willen zu sondern freiheit kommen zudem
handeln wesen oder menschen darin ist
natürlich ganz kleine theorie der
handlungsfreiheit ausgedrückt
da hier und um jedoch zu unserer
untersuchung der freie zurückzukehren so
heißt meines erachtens die richtige
frage stimmt nicht ist der wille frei
sondern ist der mensch frei
hierüber denke ich folgendes hier ist es
der mensch ist so weit frei als er durch
bestimmung oder wahl seines geistes in
dem er die existenz irgendeiner
tätigkeit oder der nichtexistenz jener
tätigkeit vorzieht und umkehrt diese
tätigkeit zu bewirken oder nicht zu
bewirken vermag und damit habe ich jetzt
probleme ist jetzt das ist jetzt das
alternative wollen gemeint oder das
alternative ton gemeint wenn wir nicht
durch einen gedanken der die bewegungen
des fingers bestimmt den bislang ruhen
den finger zu bewegung veranlassen kann
oder umgekehrt dann ist es klar dass
nicht in dieser beziehung frei bin wenn
ich durch einen ähnlichen gedanken
meines geistes die das eine dem anderen
vorzieht worte erzeuger oder
stillschweigen bewirken kann so habe ich
die fähigkeit zu reden oder zu schweigen
soweit ich nun diese weiter diese kraft
reicht zu handeln oder nicht zu handeln
je nachdem ob die entscheidung seines
teams die eine oder die andere
möglichkeit bevorzugt so weit ist ein
mensch fall
das ist also eigentlich klare theorie
der handlungsbogen denn wie könnten wir
uns jemand wie könnten wir uns jemand
freie denken als er die kraft hat zu tun
was er will also hier ist die klassische
paradigmatische formulierung der
handlungsfreiheit gegeben so weiter und
jemand dadurch dass ein handeln dem
unterlassen die ruhe an mandeln
flugzeuges handeln oder solche will wohl
zu bewirken vermag so weit kann er tun
was er will ich in solcher weise eine
handlung ihrer unterlassung vorzuziehen
heißt sie wollen und es lässt sich
schwerlich angeben wie wir uns ein wesen
noch freier vorstellen können als es
dann ist wenn es fähig ist zu tun was
ich will
dennoch erscheint also ein mensch
hinsichtlich von handlungen innerhalb
des bereichs einer solchen kraft in ihm
so frei wie die freiheit ihn nur frei
machen kann
das sind jetzt einige hinweise auf
handlungsfreiheit hinsieht des wollens
ist der mensch nicht frei allein der
visbeker geistesmenschen denen sich
jeden gedanken an eigene schuld so weit
wie möglich fernhalten will auch wenn er
sich dadurch in eine schlimmere lage
versetzt als indie der fatalistischen
notwendigkeit gibt sich hiermit nicht
zufrieden
eine freiheit die sich nicht weiter
erstreckt genügt nicht
es erscheint ihm als ein stichhaltiger
entwurf wenn gesagt wird der mensch so
überhaupt nicht frei falls es ihm nicht
ebenso frei steht zu wollen als er wolle
zu wirft man denn bezüglich der menschen
freiheit noch die andere frage auf ob
der mensch die freiheit habe zu wollen
das ist wohl auch dass hinter der
streitfrage ob der wille preisen
hier dürfte jetzt die frage auf ob wir
nicht auch willens frei sein muss ich
nicht nur handlungsfreiheit
also müssen wir auch unser wollen wollen
können unseren willen bestimmen wie
harry frank wird in dieser theorie der
27 stufen gesagt hat
inwiefern der menschen nicht frei sein
kann zu wollen
da das wollen oder die willensäußerung
ein handel ist und die freiheit in der
kraft besteht zu handeln oder
nichthandeln so kann der mensch fühlt
sich das wollen oder des paktes der
willensäußerung nicht frei sein sobald
sich eine in seinem markt stehen der
handlung seinem denken als eine sogleich
auszuführen dargestellt hat der grund
dafür liegt klar zu sagen es ist
unvermeidlich dass eine von unserem
willen abhängige handlung entweder
geschehe oder nicht geschehen das eine
wie das andere sich ganz und gar nach
der entscheidung in bevölkerung unseres
willens richtet so können wir
schlechterdings nicht umhin eines von
beiden zu wollen das heißt 1 dem anderen
vorzuziehen weil 1 und beiden notwendig
eintreten muss und das wenige was dann
ein drin auf die wahl und entscheidung
unseres kreises hin verfolgt
das heißt darauf hin dass wir es wollten
denn wenn wir es nicht wollen würde es
nicht geschehen
hinsichtlich des willens aktes ist der
mensch somit in einem solchen fall nicht
frei in die frei bestimmende kraft zu
handeln oder nicht zu handeln die der
mensch hinsichtlich der willens unter
den geschilderten umständen nicht hat
also hier haben wir noch mal ganz klar
eine theorie der handlungs bank
denn ist unumgänglich notwendig ich
glaube das haben wir schon mal
vielleicht lesen mal vor wenn ist
unumgänglich notwendig dass wir uns für
die ausführung oder unterlassung eine
unserer hand macht gegen handlung die
sich als solche einmal so denkt hat
entscheiden müssen notwendigerweise das
eine oder das andere wollen auf diese
bevorzugung oder diese willensäußerung
hin erfolgt die handlung wurde ihre
unterlassung mit gewissheit und zwar ist
70 wahrhaft willkürlich da jedoch der
akte willensäußerung oder die
bevorzugung der ein von den zwei
möglichkeiten für uns unvermeidlich ist
zu stehen wir hinsichtlich des dieses
willensakt eine notwendigkeit und da
stehen wir eine notwendigkeit können
also nicht frei sind das notwendigkeit
und freiheit zusammen bestehen können
und dement zu gleicher zeit frei und
gebunden sein könnte wenn man den
menschen in diesem sinne freiheit zu
schreibt in dem man die tätigkeit des
wollens von seinem willen abhängig sein
lässt muss man außerdem noch einen
zweiten vorausgehenden willen annehmen
der die akte des dieses dienst bestimmt
und einen dritten der wiederum diesen
bestimmt und so weiter infinitum dann
sobald der eine aufhört können die
handlungen des letzten willens nicht
frei sein
auch kann ich mir kein höher gehen das
wesen vorstellen dass eine derartigen
willensfreiheit fähig ist dass es
unterlassen kann zu wollen
das heißt dass sein oder nichtsein von
etwas das in seinen kräften steht
vorzuziehen
sobald ist dieses einer als solches
betrachtet ein wasser energy als diese
passage zum schluss noch
wir hatten schon einen denker der genau
dieses problem behandelt hatte diesen
infinitum regress höher stufiges wollen
wieder stufiges das ist der harry
frankfurt sie hat sich dass wir auch
noch munition als dritter ordnung
koalition vierte ordnung usw bräuchten
das scheint er hier auch zu behandeln
und das scheint er deswegen für völlig
sinnlos zu halten wenn wir unser wollen
noch einmal wollen können müssten
müssten wir auch dieses wollen des
wollens nochmal wollen und wir kämen nie
zu einer handlung bei wenigen letzten
finalen bilden hätten sowohl und
deswegen sagt glock die linzer haben
reicht völlig aus wir haben den willen
und zu fragen ob wir den willen wollen
müssen können ist sinnlos das ist noch
ein weiteres argument für die
unsinnigkeit sinnlosigkeit einer theorie
von willensfreiheit eins bestimmt drei
oder vier argumente von john bock gegen
freiheit des willens
ich sag mal vier argumente oder so und
diese vier argumente oder wie viel es
auch immer sind könnten sich sehr schön
in einer hausarbeit einmal genauer in
ihrem verhältnis und das suchen jetzt
blitz wiederholt sich so ein bisschen
und jetzt kommen wir zum schluss noch
auf diesen netten denker zu sprechen wir
diese sehr sehr schöne frisur weiß von
ihnen jemand wie der heißt
das ist leibnitz gottfried wilhelm
leibniz und er hat ein versuch der
menschenverstand geschrieben bzw
ganz ähnlich wie lockt er hat in seinem
werk hat er loks versuche mit
menschlichen verstand von 96 kritisiert
beziehungsweise kommentiert und das
haben wir ein paar leitfragen noch zu
guter letzt wie verhalten sich die
termin ismus und freiheit bleibt uns
zueinander
welche verschiedenen arten von frey
unterscheidet leibnitz liefern
kritisiert bzw modifiziert leibnitz den
logischen freiheitsbegriff also es geht
hier darum das leibnitz der ja ein
rationalist ist wie sie hier sehen
erst ein fazit ist dass der
willensfreiheit jetzt gegenüber
handlungsfreiheit denken möchte
es gibt die these
die müssen jetzt auch ein bisschen nur
kurz anreißen wir haben nicht mehr genug
zeit um jetzt unterscheidet ihr hier
verschiedene arten von feiert der
ausdruck freiheit ist sehr zweideutig
heißt auf französisch also ambiguität es
gibt einen rechtlichen eine tatsächliche
freiheit im sinne des rechts ist ein
sklave nicht frei ein unterstand ist ist
nicht völlig aber ein armer ist ebenso
frei werden reicher die tatsächliche
freiheit besteht in dem vermögen das zu
tun was man will
das ist also wie nennt man diese these
diese position das zu tun was man will
das ist
handlungsfelder oder eine vermögen des
richtigen wollens selbst könnte man das
nennen das wäre dann offensichtlich will
sie sprechen hier von der freiheit des
handelns und diese hat ihre gerade und
verschiedene halten allgemein ist
derjenige welcher mehr mittel hat frey
das zu tun was er will aber im besondern
bezieht man die fahrt auf den gebrauch
derjenigen dinge die gewöhnlichen
unserer gewalt sind also vor allem auf
den freien gebrauch unseres körpers in
diesem sinne sind kälte und krankheiten
dem sie uns verhindern unseren körpern
unsere glieder diejenige bewegung zu
geben die wir ihnen geben wollen und
gewinn gewöhnlich geben können
beschränkungen unserer freiheit und man
sagt das angefangene nicht frei sein
angelehnte kein fan bauch seiner glieder
haben das ist also erstmal handlungsraum
die freiheit des wollens wird
gleichfalls in zwei verschiedene
bedeutung genommen
der eine setzt man sie der
unvollkommenheit und der sklaverei des
geistes gegen hinter der geist unter
einem zwang und eine hemmung wenngleich
diese von ihnen stammen handelt wie dies
bei den leidenschaft der fall ist in der
anderen bedeutung meldet die fremd
gegensatz zur notwendigkeit im ersten
sind sagt historiker dass der weise
allein frei und in der tat ist der geist
wenn er von einer großen leidenschaft in
anspruch genommen ist nicht frei denn
man kann als dann nicht in der richtigen
weise dh mit der nötigen überlegung
wollen in diesem sinne ist gott allein
vollkommen frei die erschaffenen geister
aber sind es nur die maße als sie über
die leidenschaften haben sind und diese
freiheit betrifft eigentlich unseren
verstand die freiheit des geistes aber
welche der notwendigkeit gegen gesetz
ist betrifft wo es den willen besitzt
übrigens freiheit und zwar sofern er
sich vom verstand unterscheidet sie ist
dasjenige was man freiwillig können
womit gemeint sein soll dass der wind
trotz den stärksten gründen oder motiven
die der verstand den willen vorhält
nichtsdestoweniger immer zufällig bleibt
und keine absolute oder so
sagen metaphysische notwendigkeit
besitzt in diesem sinne pflege ich zu
sagen dass der verstand willen je nach
den vorherrschenden konzeptionen und
kunden zwar auf sichere und unfehlbare
art bestimmen kann dass er ihn aber
nichtsdestoweniger nur zu einer
entscheidung in haid macht ohne ihm zu
nötigen
das will ich jetzt einfach nur mal als
letzte tat verlassen also es geht jetzt
hier leibnitz zusammengefasst auch mal
um die freiheit des richtigen wollens
und nicht die freiheit des handelns es
geht ihm um willensfreiheit und es geht
ihm auch hier wiederum wie dass der
verstand den willen bestimmt wenn jetzt
aber der verstand den willen so
definieren würde da ist alles was der
verstand einsieht und unsere flucht
einzieht der wille auch tun muss dann
wäre der will ja benötigt wäre er gar
nicht gefallen
und jetzt bleibt uns der verstand
determiniert unseren willen nur aber er
macht ihn nicht notwendig also leibnitz
unterscheidet zwischen determination die
mit freiheit kompatibel ist und zwischen
notwendigkeit damit freiheit nicht
garantiert ist
als er möchte dass frei bestimmt ist
aber dadurch eben nicht mehr zitiert ist
dass es noch freie alternativen gibt er
war und das ist jetzt auch der
schlusspunkt der heutige sitzung also
wir wollen jetzt in der nächsten sitzung
kunst noch mal genauer anschauen wie
leibniz gegen lok willensfreiheit
verteidigt und wenn sie noch mal
einblick in diesen text werfen diese
novosti
diese neun ist im neuen aufsätze neuen
versuche dann auch neuen abhandlung dann
sehen sie dass es hier immer zwei
dialogpartner gibt es einen dialog dem
leibniz-institut und da gibt es den
theophilus es gibt noch einen anderen dh
ist glaub ich vieles wenn nicht alles
täuscht als es gibt zwei den theophilus
und dem land tirol ist praktisch der der
gott liebt und der fiel alles ist der
die wahrheit lebt und der eine werden
sie sehen ist er mit leibniz positionen
zu identifizieren und der andere eher
mit derjenigen von jim knopf als er
kommentieren eigentlich max tieren und
lesen sie sich den text nochmal durch
schicken auch die folie und schauen sie
mal wie hier jetzt leibnitz gegen lok
eine theorie von willens verhält
verteidigen möchten gegen die
angeführten argumente von block das ist
so was wie eine frage des willens aus
begrifflichen logisch und sonstigen
gründen nicht geben kann dann bis zum
nächsten